are you guys gonna get married
and stick alone
well Mom
I that that that's not really in my head
right now
[Music]
what we are more focusing on right now
is business
I hope sometime in the future we will be
thinking about that yeah
I would have never thought Everton would
have embarrassed me in front of his
family when he took me home to meet them
for the first time
[Music]
understand how Everton couldn't be
thinking about marrying me with all
we've done and the future we're moving
towards
okay
um so Mom give me a hug
it was nice meeting you too see you in a
little bit Yeah
sis thanks thanks for coming all right
thank you bro yeah bro respect every
time yeah man all right thanks one
I'm pissed I'm happy you told your
family about the business but doesn't
mean much anymore considering you
completely blew off marriage
you act like there's going to be one
without the other and it doesn't work
that way
no woman is going to sit next to a man
that's blowing off marrying her women
aren't that stupid can you can you just
calm down you don't get it if you're
gonna tell me not fine don't marry me
okay then we're gonna sell Caymans cool
I mean like that's the thing
so we should have a conversation where
we did have a conversation
with a 15 or 20 conversation you should
have said I did I'm beating my head
against a wall right now
you know what I don't know
I love Jordan a lot but ever since we've
been back together we haven't been
discussed in March we've been more
focusing on the business
so you know for her to hit me like that
you know it's not something that I did I
had expected from her
marriage is a very big commitment and
that is something that I see with her at
some point of time but I I am not even
sure if I'm ready for marriage
we don't have a conversation we're
listen I listened to what you said and
you just told all your people you blew
out marriage don't worry
[Music]